I'm Matt kirshen I'm Andy wood I'm a
Brit I'm an American and it turns out
that I have more trouble than Andy being
understood by some of these things which
writer wrote Westworld sorry I'm not
sure how to help with that so we decided
to try out three of the top smart
devices and figure out which one could
understand the widest variety of access
we picked four different censuses which
provide a variety of challenges for
accents and we're gonna bring in a bunch
of friends of ours and have them run
through those four phrases on each of
these three devices we gonna play around
with a bit we're gonna get them to use
the way they naturally speak maybe get
into and pop the accent a little bit by
the end of this we hope to be able to
crown one of these as having the best
ear city it was a favor and add
Worcestershire sauce to me shopping list
bleedin great city add Worcestershire
sauce to grocery list to the shopping
list our Dorchester Shire
salt to my shopping list add
Worcestershire sauce to my shopping list
one Alexa add Worcestershire sauce to my
shopping list I put Worcestershire sauce
on your shopping list add wish to share
sauce to my shopping list I've added
Worcestershire sauce to your shopping
list odwar Chester shy is forced to my
shopping list okay I got it was this
your sauce to your shopping list thank
you
okay Google at four Shasta sauce to my
shopping list okay I've added pasta
sauce to your shopping list maybe even
add more syllables so Krista sure and
see if Google look you calling me okay
goo good I don't wish - I shouts - sour
sauce through myself in girly stuff okay
I've had it was this your son
[Music]
sentence one was at Worcestershire sauce
to my shopping list every gadget caught
something close to it I've added Shire
sauce to your shopping list we was
Benedict Cumberbatch born warning Monday
July 19th 1976 when was Benedict
Cumberbatch born Benedict Cumberbatch
with one on July 19th
when was Benedict Cumberbatch boy he was
born on July 19 1976 when was bottle
dick Kumaresh born July 19th 1915 me
boom Bob batch when was been a
batch cumbered export it was impossible
to get Google home not to understand the
name Benedict Cumberbatch why is the key
[Music]
why Google is that copy thought of which
country hmm I'm not sure what you mean
by that question the country that Walker
dugu is the capital city of his bikini
blossom Wagga is the capital of which
country here's a summary of nation's
online here's a summary from nations
online Waga Google is the capital of
which country here the thumri our
nation's online satellite view is
showing Wagga dugu can you do an
impression I would think German accent
er what you sounded like when you were
first learning some English why God is
the capital of comes me here's a
thumb reason nation's online satellite
view is showing why
[Music]
this one was set up to fail
to begin with I'm gonna admit that I
hadn't heard of that city before today
person I had but I currently didn't know
how to pronounce it
which writer wrote museum which ride all
right Wes well missing which writer
right last well Alexa which writer wrote
Westwood hmm I can't find the answer to
the question I heard sorry I couldn't
find any theater named right a road west
which ride that I wrote Wes Borden hmm I
can't find the answer to the question
I'll just try it again and maybe just
like before maybe just hit the t's
really hard wish writer wrote Westwood
with which rail rope Wes whittled sorry
I'm not sure how to hold a bat yet which
really uh rope
Wes Wharton's sorry I'm not sure how to
help with that yet Westworld
screenwriter with Michael Crichton
Michael Crichton Michael Crichton so
which writer right Wes world was a
problem for a lot of people and I think
a lot of it comes down to that DT sound
oh that's a witch writer wrote Westworld
we set out to figure out which of these
three devices was the most versatile in
terms of understanding lots of different
accents yeah
all these devices have things that that
batch for us and worse at than the other
ones but when it just comes to
understanding how different people say
different sentences but it's clear
Google one followed by Siri followed by
Amazon we also learned that Google homes
pretty outstanding but the big winner
today is obviously Benedict Cumberbatch
okay GUP
when was Benedict on Bob oblong July
19th
okay Google when was Benedict
Cumberbatch born then a Bosch comer
Dick's born July 19 thanks for watching
and let's see your attempts at not
saying Benedict Cumberbatch
[Music]